and where we are really aiming is to
enable
enterprises to become autonomous
this is the whole idea that most of the
communication will be autonomous
and only the complicated stuff will
transfer to a human
that the humans should do what humans
should do not to act like both
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
today i'm going to meet somebody who
really embodies the idea of
entrepreneurship
meet elisrailov co-founder and ceo of
combox
ellie can't sleep at night literally
when an idea is bumped into his mind
he won't relax until he materializes it
he is an entrepreneur since he can
remember himself
and raised money for his first startup
when he was a cab driver on a ride from
jaffa to hermatave
elithelove welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you today
i feel good especially today i don't
know why i feel good
you find me in the right in the right
day
well that's exactly what i try to do
you're the co-founder and ceo of
combox and you know the world is
changing around uh software is eating
the world the
sales and and traditional communication
channels are are being disrupted on on a
daily basis at this point
uh very fragmented very difficult to
keep track of and and i'm gonna hear
soon more about this problem from you
and how you're tackling it
but but one of the things that
immediately stood out as i was looking
through
through your background is you know the
number of initiatives that you've
started and you've founded and
co-founded
so tell me a little bit about your
journey and and walk me through some of
those
you know some of those organizations and
and what what is it about
creating organizations that that really
gets you excited
okay so i think it's it's a matter of
nature
you know and and you as interpreter
yourself
you probably know that when an idea
strucks me so i i really
can't sleep like you know if it's a good
idea like you know it touches me as well
you know because there are many ideas
you know you go in the morning with the
traffic i have an idea you always have
an ideas but
sometimes that that is wow you said i
have to do that
and when this thing happens you know i
have i have always the feeling that it
can be done
and um and then my mind keeps on you
know
all all day all night and and it gives
it
it brings me a lot of energy and because
and i'm becoming addicted to that
and i'm thinking about it and i'm taking
all the puzzles and put it all
together and you know how exactly to do
that
who are the right people what exactly
the big problem the story
and you know it goes uh and you have a
feeling you have a feeling
that you're going to solve something big
so it always
it always drives you um so
i think it was since i was a kid i had
like ideas and i want to
i want to figure out a um how to
a to do it to materialize them
um so um this is what happened after
after you know after the army when i
when i started my i don't call it a
career you know
even though when i was a student by the
way when i was a student
i remember i was in in london it was the
90s so you can you can figure out how
old i am yeah because the 90s
and then it was the first time you know
i we heard about the internet it was
like 20
90 5 6 7 i don't really
don't recall exactly number but i had
i knew about the internet but then i
remember that i read the whole magazine
dotnet and like i was blown
i was like i i couldn't stop thinking
about it you know
all the application and what you can do
without it on those days they weren't
like it was the modem
and you know there was like a a site you
know there was netscape there wasn't
even
explorer netscape and in israel there
was chameleon
and then i came back to israel and
i i was sure that i'm going to do
something with that
and i said that it has to be something
with businesses
and then i remember during the night i
was working like
as a taxi driver yeah as a student there
is a
which was one of the most incredible
jobs i had
i used to watch yeah yeah it was one of
my i have
most of the story most of my best
stories up from there
from the night i'm gonna have to i'm
gonna ask you for one or two in just a
second but please continue
yeah um so i had to work in
i used to work at night and i remember i
was so you know
enthusiastic about the net so there were
a couple of the businessmen
two businessmen that and they had print
shops i don't remember even
what was the name and they came to my
cab and i took them from jaffa to to
hamatafi
and i told them about i didn't want to
do i just told them about the internet
and i told them what things you can do
with that and that's what exactly would
you do
it's not what i'm gonna what i would do
i'm going to do that and that
he said listen listen young guy we're
gonna give you a hundred thousand
dollars you're gonna eat
you're gonna be so this was my first
startup
and i i did it during during a during
i was studying it was called the
internet
so it was like trained businesses to
implement them you know uh
models in the computers they need to be
understand what you can do with that
in the business amazing but i i've done
it for a few years i don't even remember
what they wanted
so this is this is a nice story from
back then
another one it was in 2001
i think 2001 prairie to facebook
facebook was 2003. and i'm so naive the
thing that the truth is i'm naive
you know so what happened is i
i read an article if you remember a
the six degrees of separation i know
it's a
so it's such a logical article
that is back in the days in six
telephones you can get to the
uh to the prime minister or to the uh
whoever you want okay today it's in one
telephone yeah
but yeah so i said wow if you can
build a platform that connects people in
circles
that you can reach anybody so i was so
enthusiastic
and you know i put money a pocket money
and i i brought like engineers and we
built practically
a social network that didn't work
i didn't i didn't succeed i didn't
succeed like in the
in the i i didn't raise money for that
so it was very complicated you know i
thought
i can do that but it was so complicated
the the
the programmers you know gave up and
that's
so we we got in a big mess so it didn't
work out so this is also a nice story
that
i love it i love it i've done few more
things i don't even want to talk about
it but
now let's transition a little bit fast
forward and we're talking about combox
today and
you know as you're going through your
journey what what is it what led you to
think
more concretely about about sales and
communication
especially you know in the in in these
last few years
yeah very simple i
i had to get a service from orange
at the time when it was called orange
and not partner
and i i waited online it was years ago
it was eight years ago
and i waited on i don't even remember if
there was a what's up there
i waited online um
and you know the the past me through
agents and the
and i and you have to wait and you know
you have to cut your life
and then i ask myself how come i can't
you know
ask them by messenger for something to
receive service
and then uh and i said how it will it
looked so
weird to me and then i went like to
interview over there there was a guy
like academy he was like the guru of
marketing of the
orange at the time he was like the head
of marketing
and asked him and and i went to
interview him and then i interviewed a
few more
and he told me you know what ellie of
course you want to be in the digital
everybody talks about digital
transformation for years by the way
you know there's a buzzword they get a
transformation for the last four years
there's a buzzword of
artistic participation all that we talk
about
and this is about eight nine years ago
right
yeah yeah of course you want to be in
the digital but it's so complicated as a
big organization
we can do digital a little bit of chat
we can answer a little bit on facebook
but we can't really do it massively
because it's complicated because you
have to integrate
all these channels to the crm route it
to the right
agents you know there are many business
rules that has to apply to these
conversations so it becomes so
complicated and these projects are so
expensive so
we all stay in our comfort zone i said
wow
nice i said then i interviewed a few
more and then
and then we re i realized that big
companies
their major obstacle to do digital
transformation
is that it's that too many integrations
in the core systems i'm talking about
a digital transformation at scale not as
a buzzword that everybody does the
little thing
i i'll give you the numbers in a minute
but
um the the major obstacle is that
the core system the crm is a system
of documentation it's not a system of
communication
and in order to do a lot of integrity to
do digital communication at scale you
have to do so many integrations
so it becomes so complicated so they
don't do it
they're staying in the comfort zone um
so i said wow this is by the way
one problem the second problem which is
a huge problem
for years for five for the last five
years
there is like a lot of buzzwords about
um
artificial intelligence and how like the
ai and the bots will replace
agents buzzwords in a
in the a lot of you know conferences
about that blah blah blah
but practically if you're going to an
enterprise today
while we most of our as human beings
yeah
most of our communication is out of any
10 interaction eight of them is happened
by digital
and also when you go to an enterprise
and you see like 70 of the requests of
customers
can a representative request can be
automated but when you look
at these enterprises you realize that
still
70 to 80 of the communication is
telephony
and from this 70 of
a request can be that can be automated
only
five percent are automated so
it all stays in the buzzwords
everybody talking about digital
transformation and automation but
practically most of it is still
a manual most of it
is still by human agent in telephone
and i'm talking i'm not talking about
the high-tech companies i'm talking
about our sweet spot by the way
are the legacy enterprises the
complicated the banks
the insurance companies the telcos the
healthcare is
all these complicated companies that
says
we want to be digital but they can't
really it can be digital
we are like a updated and automated
digital transformation but practically
they have call centers of thousands of
people that
are doing like acting like bots okay
so we realized that in order to solve
this problem
and when you know i walked into that
startup it's not like i said okay i'm
gonna do an app
and i me i knew that it's gonna be a
robust platform
and because of my experience
like i told you about like circles that
i've done
i realized that the execution here has
to be perfect
it can't be it has to be in a platform
that's designed for enterprise bottom up
is designed for customer communication
in
all channels everything has to be
generic that can we can put
new channels very easy and the
automation
has to be part of it it has to be my our
automation he has to
integrate to all channels and it has to
work
seamlessly with the live agents so it
means that everything has to be holistic
and out of the box
in order that it will work of course
it's an enterprise solution so you can
integrate
any third party if you want to integrate
watson and that but in our philosophy
everything has to be out of the box and
it proved itself
um at the beginning as a startup
we thought you know as as a regular
startup we said we'll do one pilot
or two pilots and they and then we'll
take it from there we'll raise money
and then we realize that we hit a very
open nerve i don't know if you say it
and if it's an opener
something that is very painful for
enterprises
and we are still bootstrapped but we are
of course we are very profitable
and we have like almost 300 people and
they
and they we have like almost 300k
customers all enterprises so
so we built this platform we built this
platform
you know with our we went to enterprises
and we built it with with the customers
needs with to understand exactly what an
enterprise
is so this is practically a complex and
where we are really aiming
is to enable enterprises to become
autonomous this is the whole idea
that most of the communication will be
autonomous
and only the complicated stuff will
transfer to a human
that the human should do what humans
should do not to act like bots
this is the only i think one of the one
of the interesting things to take away
from here you know as an entrepreneur a
lot of the times we think about
you know this new world and the and the
and the cloud organizations cloud native
organizations and
and we almost forget that still most of
the world is not there
most of the world is not in the cloud
most of the world is not digital
and and those uh you know we while we
we may want to focus on the cloud native
to move forward
we can't we can't forget about how the
rest of the world works and
then our us as consumer experiences this
is again how we still experience the
world
and hopefully you know a in at some
point
everybody will be cloud native but it
will take time and there will be
industries that will take a lot of time
and so i think that what you what you're
doing is is really really interesting
what what has it been like running
through this for about nine years so so
this is not you know
one or two years this is you know a big
chunk of your life
and a big chunk of your professional
life that you're dedicating to this what
has that been like
um if like there is a term a journey
this is the term really because in that
in it's really a journey you know i i i
i learned about myself so much during
that journey
because we are not like also a typical
startup you know i think it
takes a typical startup has loads of
money
and you know is heavy and you know he's
always like
he has like his formula we're not a
typical startup
and we decided to do it differently even
though you know
now we're discussing okay we are like in
a position maybe we take money and
do like the next big step but
but it was really you know
so many so many it's really a journey
because for for me this is my longest
journey
by the way this is really my longest
in in during the and i didn't i didn't
believe it was so it would be so long
but during that journey i learned
so many things about myself it's
unbelievable
and the really i can you know it's it's
a different story
and because you know i was i felt many
times i felt like
i'm in a button you know me my
co-founder my partner
and he's a genius by himself he's like a
genius
you know he he constructed you know how
everything would work together
and we we thought together and he he
knew how to execute it
in the next two like we talked about
automation
when we did the first design of the
of the system and we knew how it's going
to look before we put the automation
inside
and how how generic it will be and all
that
so it was really really a we felt like
both of us
many times like in a battle and you know
you have your wings and you have times
that yours
your your time that times that happened
you feel like you can conquer everything
and it was really really
and it's still it's still it's still a
journey and during that journey
also the company has like you know
during the corona by the way
we doubled those down in the last three
three years we were doubling ourselves
yeah and during the corona all the
things that we teach
for for years that you have to be
automated and you have to be
digital transformation you have to
you know it's a necessity and what
happened in the corona you know
our customers wanted to be a new
customers
wanted to be more efficient wanted to
become digital so you know we have
customers today
that more than 50 percent of their
communication are running through
chromebooks
no telephone lessons and i'm talking
about big companies
so um so it's really the world is
journey
and in in evolution the company has an
evolution you know from
10 people i remember like we have a
mythological
a trip to amsterdam
we were like our first three 14 people
one four it was like
wow i remember that trip it was like
going with friends
it was amazing and now you know the
company
goes to an evolution in a trip with more
people
and parties with more people and
suddenly you know
more and more managers so you feel the
evolution of
the company but i me and my
partner are going through evolution
ourselves amazing you know
so it's really a journey this is the
term journey this is it
ellie this was so much fun thank you for
sharing
with me the stories i'm gonna have to
hear a few more stories from being a
taxi driver
in another episode but for now i have
three
short and fun questions for you and i
want to i want to take you back to your
childhood
what was what fascinated you as a kid
what was something either
you know a passion hobby or a subject in
school that really fascinated you
okay i grew by the way in a far city
called
okay it's like in there in the south
i was an asthmatic when i was a kid we
moved over there
and the truth is the most thing that
fascinated me
i had like and it still is you know to
be
in the desert i i don't know how to call
it of course i
am you know i i i you asked like
what was my thing that i liked in the in
school and all that
sort of to be in the desert i don't know
how to explain that you know
i mean it was always like something for
me i felt very
close to myself when i was in the desert
uh so the desert
really fascinates me okay not just the
desert today i live on the seas
it's like i live near the sea so all the
things that don't
doesn't have an end doesn't have an end
always fascinates me
um this is the this is one thing
um biology fascinated me
a lot i'll take it i like biology a lot
and
magics fascinated me amazing i like
magic
um that's it i feel about it
by itself you know who would serve as
some sort of inspiration for you
in the world
okay so i don't really have i thought
about it you know i don't have
this mega i have a
i have there are people first of all my
parents
really and they are very simple friends
by the way um
the people that like inspires me usually
they are like people that
i think their their main their main
character
that they never give up really i have
like a friend you know i have a friend
you know
from each person i learned something of
course but
like i have a friend that never give up
happening always in high spirit
also my mother my mother i know she
doesn't have a simple life but she never
gives up also in high school
so these are the others and my father is
very like a
he's very simple guy very very almost
a a nazir
a yeah very very simple guy
he has many many you know he is uh has a
lot of patent
he's like to make his life comfortable i
think
from here i i was i became became very
creative but
he's very efficient and very simple so
he inspires me a lot
so like many people you know i don't
have like a mega star
and also like sometimes you know writers
i don't know if you know
he's like a writer a japanese writer
that he writes also very very simple and
very very precise but
also as a human being he's a very
private human being
and he also runs a lot he's doing ultra
marathons and that
that is something that i'm very
resonating
myself and what are three words that you
would use to describe yourself
so the first one i think is motion
emotion i'm always in motion
always as i remember i'm always in
motion
and the second thing i'm always in quest
so it's something like i'm always
searching for something
always i'm since i remember myself i'm
always searching for something
um
and by the way the motion i'm addicted
to sport as well i'm not just emotion as
doing things as a doer but also like
physically i am always a
and i think the third thing is like i'm
i'm
i'm always doubt the obvious or people
that
too confident and always doubt them or
do something that is very obvious so i'm
looking at it so i said
why it's obvious like if everything says
that it's obvious
so it seems nobody really looked at it
deeply
so i'm very i'm i'm in a doubt with when
something is obvious too obvious
so i'm looking at the you know a little
bit and
suddenly you realize that many things
that are obvious in my domain
by the way also you know have you ever
asked yourself why there are telephone
numbers
why do we need telephone numbers you
know you have a booking who
remember a telephone number anymore why
do you need it
things that are so obvious and you know
in your blood and you never doubt them
there's so many things like that there
are many many things like that
so this is
so much fun thank you for your time and
this was great
thank you best of luck with combox and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
you